a third of all the people in the world
are overweight in Germany more than half
of all adults need to lose some kilos
especially men wouldn't it be great if
there was an easy way to melt away those
extra pounds a team of researchers under
the leadership of Alexander Pfeiffer at
Bonn University's Institute of
pharmacology and toxicology is
investigating how unwanted fat can be
removed from the body the first thing to
understand is that not all fat is the
same there are brown fat cells and white
fat cells white cells are the body's
biggest energy stores while brown fat
cells are energy consumers like a kind
of furnace that we have in our bodies
extra fat in the belly legs and bottom
is made up of white fat cells they're
relatively large and each contains a
single drop of fat that stores energy
white fat makes up about 1/5 of an
average person's body weight too much of
it causes problems if you consume too
much energy your white fat cells get
thicker and matter and the cells
increase in mass so you gain weight the
problem is that white fat cells are
prone to inflammation and that can lead
to secondary diseases like diabetes
heart disease or even some kinds of
cancer that are associated with obesity
figures are shafted but the cells of
brown fat tissue contain many small
drops of fat which they burn to keep the
body at a constant temperature adults
generally have about 50 grams of brown
fat in the neck and shoulder area the
scientists in Bonn have now discovered
the molecule in the body that activates
the brown cells
the neuromodulator adenosine docks on to
receptors in their membrane and
stimulates them to begin burning fat in
mice this leads to a rise in body
temperature as a matter of the film to
determine the role that adenosine plays
in brown fat we destroy the adenosine
receptors in mice you can clearly see
that the mice that lack receptors are
cooler this infrared image shows that
the mouse with intact receptors and
normal adenosine levels can activate its
brown fat tissue the white spot is where
the mouse's body is very hot because the
mouse is brown fat has been activated in
Mars activity the researchers wondered
whether white fat cells could be
transformed into brown fat cells leading
to more fat being burned and thus weight
loss white fat usually can't be
activated like brown fat because the
cells lack adenosine receptors but in a
mouse if a white fat cell is given a
gene for these receptors they form and
the white cells begin burning fat like
brown ones the result the mice lose
weight
the Zubin unset spoon we're looking for
starting points for therapy of obesity
and adiposity adenosine could be such a
starting point inducing brown fat cells
to consume energy and also turning white
cells into brown ones that not only
store but also burn energy but it will
be years before the work might lead to
an easy therapy for weight loss until
then people who are overweight will just
have to continue exercising and watching
what they eat